hey youtubers is Charlie and this week
in Walking Dead the cloud of death was
just hanging over all of the characters
just teasing guys so badly much more so
than usual the title of the episode was
alone and we also got some more
foreshadowing for the terminus or
sanctuary however you want to think
about it as has been the tradition in
almost each episode since the season
came back there are also a few major WTF
moments that made me re-evaluate which
characters I think are gonna die quick
shout out to my giveaway if you're
finding me for the first time each week
and my Walking Dead review I gave away a
gift card just as a way to say thank you
to all you guys for being so awesome all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment I'll
announce the winner in my Q&A video
tomorrow but now let's talk about our
top 5 WTF moments from the episode
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet number 5 maggie takes off looking
for Glenn so as the title implies there
was going to be some separating in the
episode and Maggie and Beth had this
weird sister mojo between them where for
some reason they were both the ones to
lose it and take off running
Maggie of course not being one to waste
resources totally use the walkers as
finger paints to help Glenn find her I
have to say it wasn't the biggest plot
point but I totally laughed and threw up
in my mouth at the same time Maggie is
so crazy so much more crazy than I think
we realized Sasha actually had this
great monologue where she talked about
getting warnings and only getting them
once
Maggie kind of got hers and even though
she realized she needed help
I wonder what's gonna happen in the next
situation like this it's not like sasha
is just gonna magically appear again and
save her number for Beth leaves Daryl in
the dust WTF this was one of my bigger
fish shaking moments in the episode we
didn't see her get in the car but it is
implied that she's the one that took off
Daryl on the other hand had this thing
that the governor had where no matter
how many Walker's pile on you they'd
always crawl away without a scratch
daryl is not invincible it's not like he
has that poncho anymore so that theory
is just gonna continue to be tested for
the rest of this season number three
Beth starts turning into Arya Stark I
love the opening scene with them so much
but I always get frustrated when
characters that are clearly smart have
just slip and falls and utterly fail
that's what I'm calling Beth stepping in
that trap it's like she can learn
Daryl's complex beau
she can't walk without falling down I
blame the writers for things like that
they're just trying to show us how Beth
thinks she's better than she really is
but I don't see why she has to be a
klutz for us to understand that putting
that aside I'll say the big question we
need to answer is is why did she tear
off in the car she must have either
totally flipped out or thought that
Daryl was dead I'm choosing to believe
that she just got scared and flipped out
because she and Daryl had just had those
long monologues about seeing the good in
everything even if the good ones never
survive
number two Bob Stokey totally gets
bitten this could really go either way
but him getting bit shot him to the top
of my death list he's an alcoholic and
addicts tend to lie a lot mostly about
drinking but something tells me that
unless his wound gets treated in the
next episode he's only gonna get worse
and he's gonna turn in the middle of the
night
hopefully he and Sasha aren't sharing a
sleeping bag at that point the other big
bob thing i noticed was his knight in
shining armor routine he's probably just
been doing that because of Sasha but I
like this Bob way better than the one
Daryl almost threw off a roof earlier
this season we all need to keep our eyes
on and though because sometimes shows
just do this they build a weak character
up so that they can tear them down I'll
say it again though Bob totally just
blew past Maggie on my list of people
that might die this season and my number
one moment clearly Daryl meeting Joe and
the psychopaths I'm choosing to think of
them as a version of the hunters from
the comic books we'll have to see if
they behave the same way that that comic
book group does but Joe's quote why hurt
yourself when you can hurt others does
not bode well this was like another
almost death scene Daryl just lying
there in the road defeated in a pile of
fail I am so glad that it was not Beth
there instead though and it's one less
bonus best moment I have to give a
shout-out to Glen who is totally gonna
find Maggie's finger paints
I love how those two totally think alike
Glen is definitely stubborn but he's not
quite as crazy as Maggie there was
actually a recent fake wedding photo of
the two of them which actually makes me
really nervous that things won't end
well for them now it's your turn let me
know what was your favorite moment or
your biggest WTF the big questions that
we need to answer you know either in
comments or in my Q&A video tomorrow are
one where did Beth go to what's going to
happen to Daryl and three what's gonna
happen to Bob Stokey overall I gave the
episode a B+
did an amazing job of just hanging the
thread of each person dying over our
heads first Maggie gets pinned then
Daryl gets pinned Bob gets full-on
bitten it doesn't stop
Sasha also had this foreboding moment
whenever they're debating terminus and
the music cue makes it seem like yes the
terminus is definitely a bad place we
don't have a lot further to go before
the finale and at the pace each group is
moving I'm really wondering if the
finale which is called a really means
Alexandria Washington is not that close
and if anyone is going to get there it's
gonna take a full tank of gas that did
just jump in a car so that could be
where she said it but let's discuss a
PHY in the comments be sure to subscribe
to get that Q&A video tomorrow we're
really only a week or two away before
someone probably finally makes it to the
terminus though right now click here to
get that Q&A video and click here to get
the latest Game of Thrones trailer that
I just posted thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you